Ryan Reynolds has always been a
fun-loving good-looking guy but if you
compare his early days in Hollywood to
his more recent out saying as everyone's
favorite foul-mouthed superhero you
might notice that he hasn't always had
the beefed up physique that looks so
good in red spandex how did this former
child actor turn his body from lean to
mean be warned there aren't any tricks
just time energy and dedication it's all
began with blade Reynolds big comic book
movie breakthrough came over a decade
ago when he played vampire hunter
Hannibal king in the 2004 film blade to
Trinity trainer before we started the
film wanted to pack on about 10 pounds I
mean and masala in the three months
before filming began Reynolds was
whipped into good enough shape to occupy
space in a superhero flick if not had
Loman himself the secret long workouts
heavy weights and zero cardio because
believe it or not before he parked on
the muscle to play this role when
Reynolds was kind of a noodle every day
is a gym day want to be a superhero
prepare not to slack off ever some of
the routines Reynolds has to follow
border on the sadistic for instance when
he first had to bulk up for Green
Lantern the actor worked out seven days
a week
90 minutes a day and never did the same
workout twice for six straight months
even his rest days just involved a less
intense type of exercise like Pilates
but don't worry for those of us who
aren't putting our ABS on display for an
audience of millions 20 minutes of
moderate exercise daily and the three
gym sessions per week will be more than
adequate to keep you fit he eats all of
the food when it comes to playing
Deadpool the first time Reynolds suited
up wasn't in his own standalone film it
was in 2009 s x-men origins Wolverine a
regrettable outing that would eventually
become the birth of Deadpool's best
marketing jokes but the movie that was a
career-low for me you understand but
back then the actor wasn't going to pass
upon the chance to bring Wade Wilson to
life on screen and he had to bulk up
fast
which meant consuming enormous amounts
of food Reynolds said that he had to eat
live children in order to put on so much
muscle in so little time but he was
kidding of course probably he focuses on
nutrition the theme of any good
superhero diet protein protein and
protein and if you're Ryan Reynolds
plenty of carbs too the actor says I
really don't believe in that no carb
stuff it's probably not good for you and
makes you pretty cranky
amount of exercise will make up for poor
nutrition eating the right foods and the
right amounts and at the right times if
you're being really intense about it is
key to building a physique like this one
that said even superheroes get the
occasional cheat day to indulge in some
nuts or healthy foods like it's a
chimichanga but actually reynolds
prefers to gorge on pizza when he
doesn't have to look ripped on-screen he
keeps it tight when Reynolds might shed
some muscle or change of his work out
between superhero flicks but he's
basically being in battle ready shaped
for the past 15 years which makes it
easy to rump things back up when he
needs to slide into a spandex suit
according to his longtime trainer Bobby
Strom for action films he was 200 pounds
at 8 percent body fat for rom-coms
he's about 180 and 11 percent body fat
but even then Reynolds as a gym regular
say Strom when he does a comedy he
probably goes to the gym to do cable
work every other day he sets challenging
goals Reynolds has said that getting in
shape for movie roles left him
astonished at what could be achieved
with a solid workout regimen and now he
keeps himself motivated by giving
himself new goals to strive for of
course for someone has fit as Reynolds
those goals have to be pretty intense
among the items already crossed off his
bucket list is running the New York City
Marathon in under four hours next up he
wants to climb Machu Picchu he has fun
with it ultimately Ryan Reynolds
approaches Fitness the same way he
approaches well everything by not taking
himself too seriously sometimes that
means finding motivation in unusual
places like a friendly rivalry with his
Deadpool 2 co-star Josh Brolin who got
even more muscled up than Reynolds to
play the character cable but the actor
also knows his limits and isn't afraid
to point out when another superhero star
has surpassed him in physical
achievement when asked how his own
regimen stacked up against Hugh
Jackman's he would wake up at 2 o'clock
in the morning in order to eat enough to
fuel his Wolverine workouts Reynolds
said Hugh Jackman has a dedication to
his craft that I'm afraid I don't share
if I'm up at 2:00 in the morning it's
because something has gone terribly
wrong that laid-back attitude keeps the
actor sane and it doesn't hurt that it's
totally in character yeah that's really
hard on your knees totally impractical
thanks for watching click the loop icon
to subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
your love to
[Music]